hello italy has won the euro 2020
football championship
beating england in a nail-biting penalty
shootout
this was the scene in rome when the
italian goalkeeper saved england's final
attempt
italy has now secured their first
european championship trophy
in 53 years the game at wembley stadium
saw 65 000 spectators in the stands for
the first time
since the pandemic began
let's go live to paul brennan who's
outside london's wembley stadium so
terrible disappointment i imagine there
well scarcely has so much expectation
being heaped on the shoulders of such a
young team to be honest many of them in
their early 20s
but the reality was that many people
believe this was england's best chance
of scooping a major football tournament
for many many years they had several
advantages they had home advantage for
example all three of their group games
were here at wembley the quarterfinal
they went to rome and played ukraine but
then they were back here
at wembley for the semi-final and now
this final they had what many people
believed was the easier side of the draw
to get here for the final and yet yet
again england fall at the final hurdle
and the most cruelest
of ways through penalties uh it seems
that england just have this who do
when it comes to penalty shootouts after
extra time i'm going to step just out of
the way for a second
you can see the fans thronging out it's
been a party
here outside the stadium for hours and
hours and hours since way before two
o'clock this afternoon
many ticketless fans i'll step back in
many ticketless fans simply came down to
the stadium
to soak up the atmosphere to drink
alcohol
to eat food to chant and sing
those 65 000 fans lucky enough to get
tickets and go
in with biting uh through the whole game
uh there was they expected there was a
hope at the start uh when the when
england scored
uh luke shaw just after two minutes but
then they seemed to
seem to lose their way uh particularly
in the second half
italy really bossing that second half
england's kind of
composing themselves for the final
minutes of the 90
then into extra time no breakthrough and
penalties and yet again
england fall short paul brennan thank
you very much across now to adam rainey
who's live for us in central rome and if
you can hear me there must be a
completely different atmosphere there
after that win
[Music]
definitely lauren unbridled joy a total
release
during that that those penalties it was
such stress here
uproarious joy uproarious screams of
passion and fear that they were going to
lose it all
all within 30 seconds every passion
imaginable in a football match
we'd seen this match go back and forth
from the beginning when
england went up 1-0 just two minutes in
and then there was a long lull here of
just
quiet as people watched waiting for
italy equalized
they finally did and from then they saw
that italy was on the attack and then
when it went extra time and went into
penalties
there was just an intense amount of
passion and joy and stress
palpable here in the shadow of the roman
coliseum
walking around during throughout the
game you saw people watching in
restaurants bars
everyone rapturous watching this team a
team that has
captivated the nation in this wake of
the worst days of the pandemic in italy
the country that had
suffered uh kobit 19 worse than any
other western country
earliest still one of the highest death
rates in all of of europe so there was a
lot more happening here than just
football lauren there was
a whole country's hopes passions and
feeling of freedom of
being able to celebrate together
something
after so many long months of being
cloistered with just families
in their homes and perhaps just going
back and forth to work in school so
a lot of joy here on display people very
happy and it was such a
intense final few moments to witness it
here and it happened as we were
as we were live with andy and you
earlier in the last bulletin
and that's what it feels like and tell
us about the journey that this team have
had i mean they've had an extraordinary
run and they were there
well it's now 34 um on 34 matches
unbeaten it is quite extraordinary isn't
it
it's it's a huge achievement considering
this happened also in the wake of such a
devastating
2018 world cup and which italy didn't
even qualify for the finals
so we saw this country battered by the
pandemic battered by recent football
history and this team just captivated
people and
under the directorship under the
leadership of uh coach
roberto mancini italy really rallied
around him as this larger than life
personality that
that shaped this team and made it able
to come back like this in such a short
time
to come in and claim victory in this
very
important tournament a tournament that
played on the home field of england
their opponent
seemed like history might be playing for
them but italy
pushed they took back the momentum in
the
in the second period and then got a
lucky break perhaps in the penalties and
took it home
thanks very much indeed adam rainey
there live in rome for us